[Music]
from space our planet appears to be more
ocean than earth but despite the water
covering 71% of the planet's surface
more than half the world's population
Andorra's extreme water scarcity for at
least one month a year and current
estimates predict that by 2040 up to 20
more countries could be experiencing
water shortages taken together these
bleak statistics raise a startling
question are we running out of clean
water well yes and no at a planetary
scale earth can't run out of fresh water
thanks to the water cycle a system that
continuously produces and recycles water
morphing it from vapor to liquid to ice
as it circulates around the globe so
this isn't really a question of how much
water there is but of how much of it is
accessible to us 97% of Earth's liquid
is saltwater - loaded with minerals for
humans to drink or use in agriculture of
the remaining 3% of potentially usable
freshwater more than two-thirds is
frozen in ice caps and glaciers that
leaves less than 1% available for
sustaining all life on Earth spread
across our planet in rivers lakes
underground aquifers ground ice and
permafrost
it's these sources of water that are
being rapidly depleted by humans but
slowly replenished by rain and snowfall
and this limited supply isn't
distributed evenly around the globe
diverse climates and geography provides
some regions with more rainfall and
natural water sources while other areas
have geographic features that make
transporting water much more difficult
and supplying the infrastructure and
energy it would take to move water
across these regions is extremely
expensive in many of these water poor
areas as well as some with greater
access to water
humanity is guzzling up the local water
supply faster than it can be replenished
and when more quickly renewed sources
can't meet the demand we start pumping
it out of our finite underground
reserves of Earth's 37 major underground
reservoirs 21 are on track to be
irreversibly emptied so while it's true
that our planet isn't actually losing
water we are depleting the water sources
we rely on at an unsustainable pace this
might seem surprising after all on
average people only drink about two
liters of water a day but water plays a
hidden role in our daily lives and in
that same 24 hours
most people will actually consume an
estimated 3000 liters of water in fact
household water which we use to drink
cook and clean accounts for only 3.6
percent of humanity's water consumption
another 4.4 percent goes to the wide
range of factories which make the
products we buy each day but the
remaining 92% of our water consumption
is all spent on a single industry
agriculture our farms drain the
equivalent of 3.3 billion Olympic sized
swimming pools every year all of it
swallowed up by crops and livestock to
feed Earth's growing population
agriculture currently covers 37% of
Earth's land area posing the biggest
threat to our regional water supplies
and yet it's also a necessity so how do
we limit Agriculture's thirst while
still feeding those who rely on it
farmers are already finding ingenious
ways to reduce their impact like using
special irrigation techniques to grow
more crop per drop and breeding new
crops that are less thirsty other
industries are following suit adopting
production processes that reuse and
recycle water on a personal level
reducing food waste is the first step to
reducing water use since one third of
the food that leaves farms is currently
wasted or thrown away
you might also want to consider eating
less water intensive foods like shelled
nuts and red meat adopting a vegetarian
lifestyle could reduce up to one third
of your water footprint our planet may
never run out of water but it doesn't
have do for individuals to go thirsty
solving this local problem requires a
global solution and small day-to-day
decisions can affect reservoirs around
the world so where will these global
solutions come from and how can we
humans famously set in our ways
make sure these changes stick lucky for
us a generation of young people is
already committed to a cleaner greener
future and many of them are sharing
their innovative ideas through Ted Ed's
student voice program if you're under 18
and think you might have an idea worth
sharing
sign up to gain access to our free
curriculum and learn how to fine-tune
your idea and share it with the world
visit Edie
Ted comm student talks to learn more